really quickly to tie it back to true
crime i don't know if you ever saw the
keeper the keepers on netflix it was
about the do you see that it was the
keeper or keepers the keepers there was
this moment where the nun
who was murdered
the killer like is this real yeah he had
her he got her he did he took her vagina
i didn't even know like how what the
incision is to get the full it's a
scooper
but not like a melon but like
it's
picturing but like no ice cream on not a
melon ball i'm sorry oh excuse me miss
high society you and your melons and
your chinese fruits like wow
i mean i wonder if you think about
women's bodies being just as when you
eat melons you just think of dead women
but whatever so maybe like a gelato no
no it was like you know those things
that cut apples for you
like you just
you know it's probably one of those i
was well whatever it was anyway yeah he
took the jewelry it's definitely a shark
tank thing
whatever it is
yes um
anyway he
neither of us cooks
i started you during the pantomime
whatever but he but um
there was just like this moment in this
whole nine
nine episode documentary where they're
just like and then he took her vagina
and it was in tin foil and he threw it
on the table and then that they never
talked about it again
it was like one line in nine episodes
and it was just like this
bomb and
and and it's all i can ever think about
it was just
like a nun this poor dead nuns vagina he
scooped it out with like a i still think
it's like because it it was probably
what they cut the um
wafers i mean there's there's a lot of
things if you sit in church long enough
you're like i i could
definitely suffer vagina with that you
get so bored after you know what i mean
what i don't have anything else
so what why did the person want to do
this it wasn't i don't know anything i
think it could have been its own nine
episode
sure but it was just like the keepers
and they they this guy killed a bunch of
things i didn't know i didn't know the
vagina like separated from the body i
just thought it was like
it doesn't you have to
look i i i think i think he separated it
and i know i know but it's like if you
wasn't like your anal sphincter coming
out nobody's like i i picture like if
you're gonna
i think it was just her clit i think
they should have said clit okay because
i think i know where you're getting
it's not like mr potato head he just
like pulled the vagina out and it was
like fully like a plastic
sometimes they prolly but i think that
whoever made this movie was obviously a
man and they don't know the difference
between a vagina and a clitoris and they
just
but hold on you think about it you make
tv shows for like so you wouldn't say
threw her clitoris on the table it just
said that i understand that's crazy
though no that is with an ice cream
scoop
that i think
he got some lips
so they were like it's let's just call
it a vagina you know how many meetings
they had about this
they settled on vagina because they
thought it'd be the least confusing and
here you are
[Music]
interesting they had so many meetings
like they're like technically it was
just her like lips and a clit and like
maybe some
like like a smattering of things
you know there needs to be like more
yeah i think that the forensics people
were like we don't even know what this
is
they couldn't tell
they're like is this
i think what didn't what if the
forensics were men
and then
it's just like where does the vagina
stop and the rest of the woman begins
people would know because they could've
been her whole body that's just a vagina
as far as i'm concerned
[Music]
uh
[Applause]
you